[Musique]
c'est dans le périgord vert à la limite
de la charente et du limousin que nous
avons trouvé la recette de se farcit
périgourdins qui comme la plupart des
plats régionaux est l'expression d'un
terroir d'un mode de vie traditionnel
exactement nous sommes à piégut une
commune connue pour ses champignons ces
escargots ses étangs et son donjon
moyenâgeux c'était une région de
polyculture et d'élevage et ça l'est
resté d'ailleurs en grande partie
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est madame gaby bonnefont dont toute
la famille est issu d'une la commune de
piégut qui a confectionné donc pour nous
se farcit périgourdin la recette que
vous avez préparé que vous allez de
préparer aujourd'hui c'est une recette
typiquement périgourdine de nos grands
mères
c'est une recette du périgord vert que
mes grands mères et arrière grands mères
la mère de gaby bonnefont réel et est
ménée triaire c'est-à-dire qu'elle
emmené les cortèges de mariée en jouant
du saxophone et elle confectionnait
toujours ce plat le jour du mardi gras
jour là tout un tas de choses
accompagnant le fameux farsi et on
buvait exceptionnellement du café ce
jour-là et également du vin et oui le
vin et le café était un luxe à l'époque
dans ce coin du périgord vous on
pourrait purement j'ai bien d'autres
fois
alors pour ne pas avoir la tentation
d'en manger jusqu'au samedi jour où
s'était permis on intérêt les restes
comme ça mais tu es sûr que personne
n'ait touché grâce à nous très tendu
oh
[Musique]
cette époque difficile que vient
d'évoquer gaby bonnefont n'est pas si
lointaine et monsieur gautier le
cordonnier du village s'en souvient
parfaitement de mes parents les
amendements mais il était pauvre et pas
été à l'école et alors quand les normes
et cigale en dix ans j'étais ont baissé
dans les fermes et comme les comparses
étaient pas les billets de chocolat
comme c'étaient des coutrillons ouvert
et des vols
[Musique]
monsieur gautier c'est un cordonnier pas
comme les autres il a été longtemps
cordonnier ambulant de village en
village et depuis quelques années il a
installé sa roulotte en plein coeur de
pieds cubes bon oui et c'est vous qui
l'avez construite la halle carbon
entièrement g8 17 jours pour leur
construit entière mammeri cheyrou à tous
et roule
vous fêtez les tournées oui c'est vous
qui avez fait toutes ces sculptures qui
sont autour eh oui l'avion si c'est vous
l'avions d'hélicoptères nique au caire
l'armée ni la personne ni la charge
alors de faire des conneries débitées
bricoles comme ça qu'on ne pouvait les à
bout je le fais et c'est le travail
simon tu as appris lors du ca vous
allongez supporter reeves à la tour est
ce qu'elle est on bien fait mon tour ah
oui elle est en gros ni ses hangars
l'item pierre et j'aime tellement mon
métier là et je vois des petites femmes
la caisse couler mais alors ça me permet
de vivre heureux mais revenons ségali
bonnefont et revenons à notre farce
bon il a fait des choses pour faire mais
oui oui alors on va énuméré alors on
prépare d'abord la soupe un pot-au-feu
pas dans lequel on met et tous les
ingrédients habituels
le poireau les carottes des navets un
oignon piqué de trois coups de girofle
une branche de céleri une branche de
thèmes et non ça c'est pour le ces pour
la farce dans la soupe c'est un peu plus
tôt lors du sel et du poivre
alors les pommes de terre en les
ajoutant même un con mais le farsi et en
plus de tous ces légumes
il y a également différentes sortes de
viande dans le pot-au-feu
alors vous commencez par quoi d'abord je
fais mans bouillon n'est ce pas je
voudrais pas mon pot-au-feu dans lequel
je mets mon petit salé que vous voyez
plus la gemme demi museau de porc un
tout ça je les fais des salles et depuis
la veille au soir
alors je le mets cuire à l'eau froide
vers 8 heures du matin
et puis quand quand le bouillon bout je
mets mon j'arrête beau jeu même en
jarrest beau et ainsi que tous les
légumes que j'ai préparé je mets du
poivre en grains et jeux salle parce que
ma viande est quand même des salaires et
de réduire ça ça va cuire au moins deux
heures avant la préparation du farsi
deuxième opération c'est ça on commence
par couper le pain du farsi ça en
général on le fait la veille au soir
je stresse moins d'un petit peu oui et
les feuilles de chou qu'est ce que vous
en faites un éveil des choux ce sont des
choux âge comme vous voyez les dix
écrans chou qu'on donne en général aux
bêtes mais quand c'est bien puis vous
savez c'est bon vous verrez alors oui à
l'asam serre envelopper le farsi voilà
pour la présentation et le filet c'est
un ancien vous voyez il est même
raccommoder et tout il avait été fait
par un de maison alors c'est bien plus
pratique que de le que 2 le fils l'aient
autrement alors je m'en sers pour pour
tenir mes feuilles de chou mais vous le
verrez tout à l'heure alors là là il
faut que les est bouillante 1
je vais d est bouillante et une première
fois voilà
il y en a peut être tort mais enfin ça
ne
je ne vais pas tout mettre parce que je
pense que j'en ai trop préparé à les
jeux mais celle là encore ça y est alors
je vais les ébouillanter une première
fois dans l'eau comme ça pourquoi
et parce que ça enlève d'abord le bout
de verre c'est mieux et après je les
passe une seconde fois dans le bouillon
parce que non seulement ça dégraisse le
bouillon mais les choux sont beaucoup
plus le moelleux à manger voilà alors
vous voyez ça ça va être ça va être fait
parce que c'est tout de suite
ébouillanté épiler les choux sont plus
digeste aussi naturellement oui là
j'éteins et puis je vais les passer
d'amendé
[Musique]
du talon de jambon d eux un mélange
d'échalotes d'ail et de persil voilà ce
qu'il faut en plus du pain pour faire le
party car si je vais mettre deux pommes
de terre pour ceux qui n'aiment pas les
carottes les choses comme ça dans le
poteau c'est ça parce qu'il faut il est
essentiel que mon bouillon soignants
quoi quand je vais mettre le farsi il ne
faut pas qu'ils s'arrêtent de bouillir
sens alors entrerez dans le farsi alors
allons-y vite alors maintenant je vais
je vais commencer d'abord voilà le pain
préparé alors avec le pain je mets mon
talon de jambon et un petit peu de
jambon de pays très peu parce que ça
brille trop n'est ce pas il ya la clim
est du l'armée je trouve que ça passe
mieux comme ça moi attendez voilà c'est
ça mais très peu de gens m'ont dit alors
je mets mon père s'y est un petit peu
d'échalotes mais pour que je coupe un
peu plus d'ailleurs je le mets mais je
vais couper dopera la passe voilà
hossa n'a pas besoin d'être coupé très
ferme enfin il faut bien faire quand
même parce qu'une fois ce prix on le
trouve pas je pense que oui la valeur
d'une demie criant café demi cuillère à
café
alors je mets une bonne gouttes de
cognac tout près combien bros wii de
tibère oui à peu près comme ça et
maintenant je vais humain c'est mon pain
avec mon bouillon voilà live arrive à
tromper alors une de droit je vais
regarder si ça va là les quatre voilà je
vais regarder si sympa ça ne brille
guère moins s'il n'a pas tout à fait
assez parce que mon phare s'y est
préparé pour une dizaine de personnes
est là ce matin
bien trop peu voilà alors pendant que ça
va finir de 30 et je vais préparer le
plat pour ferme en phase i
comme vous voyez j'ai passé mon fils est
à l'eau parce que 7e c'est un défi les
accommoder d'ailleurs à que je coure
machine pour qu'elle ne perde pas debout
et alors je vais commencer regarnir le
fil de la dernière le filet des cinq
plages ou pas voilà alors je commence
par une feuille dans le fond je tape mon
moulin une feuille d'infos après je
voyais mes feuilles de chou j'ai enlevé
la côte est pour que ce soit d'abord
moins de dire et puis elles sont plus
souples
voilà alors je les fais sur chape et
naturellement voyez
se recouvrir nous voilà c'est ça parce
que quand je les camps je referme ma
femme comme ça je le prends dans 2 dans
l'autre sens
voilà alors je prends les yeux et je
vais laisser les casser sans abîmer des
cooking parce que la coutume voulait qu
autrefois on enfile ses coquilles sur
une ficelle et y en attendaient en
général au plafond et un pack vivriers
plus utile à pâques on l'écrasé ces
coquilles et on allait les disperser
dans le champ de blé pour que pour
préserver la récolte en même temps kobe
nice et toutes les récoltes d'ailleurs
avec de l'eau bénite sa préserver la des
calamités voilà la récolte des calamités
alors comme vous voyez je vais en mettre
une bonne dizaine je vais voir selon
marc pas seulement la couleur mais là la
consistance du oui c'est ça il faut pas
qu'il soit trop mou non plus alors
légaux qui doivent rester dans la maison
comme ça de mardi gras jusqu'à pâques
mais on les gardait aussi toute l'année
chaque fois qu'on faisait quelque chose
à la maison mère dé toute l'année parce
que ces coquilles 2 servait également à
mettre dans les cendres de la lessive
parce qu autrefois il y avait pas de il
y avait pas de détergents règle
de produits blanchissants c'est ça alors
on blanchit c'est avec décembre et on y
mettez quelques coquilles d'oeufs ça a
aidé à blanche veut la paix intérieure
ah ben non voilà tout étant bien
mélanger bien mike sylla vous allez voir
je vais mettre tous à d'amples
dans le pelage par terre quand même
ouais alors maintenant il faut
recommencer par la dernière mais voilà
on recommence pas la dernière et et
ainsi de suite on replie tout le fun
voilà on les replis bien soigneusement
voilà et maintenant j'ai ajouté quand
même puisque les faits il ne me manque
pas j'en ajoute une enfin comme ça je
serai sûr que ça ne fuira pas et alors
il ya une petite fille celle qui
coulisse comme vous allez voir et je
vais m'attacher et ça va me faire une
petite bouille toute ronde que je vais
mettre un bon bouillon
voilà donc bouillon qui étonnera
toujours oui ça vaut pas il faut pas du
tout qui s'arrête quand n'est pas que je
sers quand même assez voilà ça y est
regardez si si les jolies menti farci à
ben voila quand vous voyez ça boue alors
laissez cuire au moins une heure je vais
me retourner
au moins trois fois incertaine
[Musique]
je commence alors qu'est ce que c'est ça
paraît solide
voilà alors là vous allez la tis allez y
compris le museau de porc et de ce côté
c'est du jarret de veau et légumes au
milieu naturel
voilà bondi en partie du blâme et je
vais chercher le fameux merci voilà le
fameux farsi place moi je vais vous le
défaire et vous allez le coupé vous
savez qu'en principe les femmes de
couper jamais de faire si je prends le
couteau
voilà alors en principe oui c'était
toujours le maître de maison qui le
faisait alors on ne rit jamais à
beaucoup plus tard si c'est un moment
cela mène alors pour commencer comme ça
parmi les voilà au milieu et maintenant
vous leur couper comme ça de chaque côté
ça se coupe pas comme autre chose
[Musique]